-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Ethan Hawke.
You have scooched over a little.
-I have. I'm sorry I encroached.
It's a little bit like havin
a chaperone at a date.
You know, like in high school.
You know, you had to --
-And we're -- you know,
obviously we're working out.
You did get a COVID test,
which we appreciate...
-I did, yeah.
-...in order for you
to come into the studio,
you had to do that,
and we did have our -- you know,
we're very lucky to have peopl
who are keeping an eye on things
for us.
And they did come out during the
commercial break and said like
"I think maybe one more."
-I appreciate that.
-Yeah, exactly. Safety first
So, you know, I feel like we
all, you know, there's maybe
at least one paragraph
in American history books
about John Brown.
Harper's family --
Harper's Ferry, excuse me.
We could tick those boxes.
James McBride made this really
interesting choice in his book
There's a lot of levity.
There's a lot of humor
that comes through
in the series as well.
Did you though think,
"Oh, this is so cool
that I get to not just tel
the story of James Brown --"
Sorry, John Brown.
-James Brown.
That would be
a good movie too.
-Why wasn't James Brown in this?
I don't know much about history.
-I don't know!
-But you get to tell
the John Brown --
not the history books versio
but the James McBride version,
which seems like it must hav
been a lot more fun.
-That's the reason to do it.
Nobody really wants to
be taught.
I mean, as much as we all like
our local librarian, you know,
that's not what
you tune in for movies.
-Right.
-You want to be entertained.
And what McBride did is
pull off a magic trick,
which is to talk about some of
this nation's greatest pains
some of its greatest hurts
and to do it with so much wi
and love that it disarms you
You know, you're used to
feeling like if you have t
look at this, you know,
dark part of U.S. history
that you're going to --
that it's just going to hurt
And it does hurt,
but he does it with so much love
that it hurts in a way
that is healing, I found.
I mean, when I was first reading
the book, I was sitting ther
in my bed and I'm just laughing,
you know?
I keep cackling, and my wife's
like, "What are you reading?
And I said, you know,
"The Good Lord Bird."
And she's like,
"Isn't that about John Brown?"
I'm like, "I know!"
'Cause it's kind of as if --
I don't know --
Chris Rock, Redd Foxx,
or Richard Pryor told you
the story of John Brown.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's not --
It has an incendiary quality
to it.
And I think that, as you know,
humor is a great teacher.
Humor doesn't lie.
You know, when your body
just laughs,
your brain doesn't laugh.
So you don't have
a political attack on it.
You just have an emotional human
hit on the story.
So that's absolutely
why I wanted to do it.
-And then, obviously, you pu
together an incredible cast,
which this has
up and down the board.
And one cast member,
obviously close to you,
we've talked about her before,
your daughter Maya,
was in it as well.
I mean, it must be so fun
to get to work with her,
not just because
she's your daughter
but because of
her immense talent.
-Well, it's a little
mind-blowing, you know?
People are often all over
the Internet and news
and TV shows and stuff,
you know, trying to stay young
trying to talk about
how awful it is getting old.
And then you find yourself
on a set, telling a story
that you really want to tell
that you have a passion to tell,
and your 22-year-old daughte
wants to tell it with you.
And she's got ideas
and she has --
she has a grace that she gav
the show that I didn't kno
that we needed so badly.
The funny thing about it
was that I really wanted May
to play this part,
and I was kind of scared
to bring it up with her and kind
of scared to bring it up
with Showtime because I wa
worried they would think
I was just
a crazy, nepotistic dad,
and so I was like,
"How am I gonna bring this up?
And then "Stranger Things"
came out.
And then somebody from Showtim
called, "Hey, you know,
we're looking at
the part of your daughter.
I mean, would your actual
daughter be interested?"
"Oh, what a fascinating idea!"
Like, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
And so it all just
kind of fell into place,
and they were glad to have her
and I was glad to have her
and she was happy to be there.
-You seem to have a closenes
with all your kids.
It must help
when you're actually on se
because it doesn't seem like -
I don't know --
that you're an intimidatin
father figure that --
-I try to be intimidating.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it just doesn't take
I mean, I've seen
all your kids with you.
They do not seem
even the littlest --
-Not a little intimidated?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I'll tell you this.
With all my kids this is true,
but Maya is the oldest,
and so I know it more deeply
I've been working with May
since she was a little girl.
She's an incredibly --
She has an album out right now
called "Blush"
if anybody wants to get it
She's a really gifted youn
woman, and she always has been
So we used to work on
watercolors, and she would say
"Oh, I don't really like that.
Do you think
that's too much red?
Do you think that looks more
like a dog or a bird?
Hmm, let's switch it out."
But she's always been gifted
and we've always had
an easy dialogue about art
I think one of the things that
was most difficult about her
being on set was asking myself
"Am I the actor
I told her I was?"
You know?
-Oh, right.
-Do you know what I mean?
Here I've been --
For years, I've been telling her
to respect acting.
I'm giving her Uta Hagen's book.
I'm talking to her
about what is an actor.
What does it mean?
Because the world tells yo
one thing that it is, but fo
the people who really do it,
who are committed to
storytelling and committed t
being inside the metaphor
of a play,
it's a little bit
more mysterious.
And I had to be the person -
You know?
Every time I go to the craft
service table, I'd be like
"A real actor doesn't need
this many gummi bears!"
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway, it was great.
-It turned out great.
Thank you so much
for making the trip.
I look forward to seeing you
outside of here soon.
Always a pleasure, Ethan.
-Yeah, thanks.
I'm sorry I had to sit so far.
Maybe on our second date
I get to go to here
and if things go really well
a third, here.
-Yeah, I'm very much
looking forward to it.
We're getting the thumbs-u
from the staff over there.
The finale of
"The Good Lord Bird"
airs this Sunday at 10:00 p.m.
on Showtime.